to dive right into it I'm Andrew Theriot
I'm the chief data officer for the city
of Boston I lead a team of about 20
people mix of data scientist engineers
performance analyst GIS specialists you
know people covering a wide range of
different analytics and data science
related areas
prior to this I did a PhD in political
science I did consulting in the data
science world for a few years and then
most recently before my current position
I was head of data science at the
Democratic National Committee so I've
worked on a bunch of different projects
across a wide range of field and I'm
going to talk today about some of them
that I've worked on because I've made a
lot of models in my time and I've made a
lot of mistakes I think that's a me but
that's something that anybody who's done
this for a while will understand that
that's how you learn and so what I
wanted you today is to share some of the
things that I've learned along the way
through a lot of trial and error and
hopefully you can use them in your own
work and find them find them beneficial
so what I'm going to talk about is what
I call sustainable machine learning
models and what I mean by this
our models that use the outputs of one
run of the model to generate the
training data that's used to update the
models in the future so some of the
examples of what this might look like an
obvious one is recommender systems which
I think a lot of you in the data science
world are familiar with where you know
you take what you know about a a
particular audience and you recommend
them whether it's a product or a TV show
to watch or what have you but then you
get data back you learn you know what
they clicked on or what they bought and
you can use that data to improve your
model similarly if you're trying out
different kinds of ads or targeting
different people with marketing and so
forth
all of these things are our areas in
which you can use the results of your
model to generate training data and it's
a special class of models that I'll I'll
dive into and explain why they're why
they're unique and what kinds of best
practices you should take as you go into
this world so what exactly is different
about these kinds of models well to
start off set the precedent I think this
is gonna look very familiar to anybody
who's done machine learning this is a
pretty traditional process you start out
by collecting your data you process it
you train a model you validate that
model and you make a prediction and
maybe you put it into production and you
slap an API on top so you can generate
predictions
as needed maybe you go back and get more
data later and run through the process
again this time in a bit faster method
but the point here is that your data
collection is independent of the last
step of the the predictions by contrast
in what I call a sustainable machine
learning model there's two different
steps so the first thing is this last
six step deployment where you're
actually using the predictions you
generate so that might be you know
targets for people to contact or direct
advertising to it might be
recommendations for products or movies
or what have you it might also be
something like you know a recommendation
for somewhere to inspect or audit
something about data quality something
about for example in the city of Boston
we use a similar system to target our
restaurant inspections these are all
kinds of things where you're taking
these predictions you're immediately
putting them out into the world and
using them to feedback into that first
step that outcome and feature collection
and then the second thing that's
different here in the process is the
retraining and revalidation steps where
because you're doing this over and over
and over again you often end up handling
those differently than you would if you
were just doing it the first time
through for example by automating some
of these processes or simply you know
building in to your production ization
automatic updates as they go in a way
that you know will alert you if
something goes wrong but doesn't require
you to have hands on keyboards every
time that this gets updated so why is
this really that big a deal well a few
things one there's really no perfect way
to optimize for something like this you
know if you're just trying to build a
one-off model where your only goal is
the best accuracy possible you know the
best fit in that one time you run
through that's easy we've got plenty of
metrics for that you know anybody who's
spent more than 20 minutes looking at
scikit-learn who's probably dug into you
know the metrics module and really come
to understand a lot of things through
there but you know there's no one metric
for something like this because you're
getting into the world of what's called
the exploration exploitation trade-off
any of you have done work with
experimentation particularly getting
beyond just basic a/b testing into
things like multi armed bandits you're
probably familiar with this idea that
you know you you're optimizing
several things you want to do as well as
possible right now but you also actually
want to learn and so there's actually a
benefit to not you know exploiting your
model fully in one moment because if you
make errors you learn from them going
forward and ultimately there's no
perfect formal solution for these kinds
of models it's very you know I hate to
say have an artistic process in a way
because no two models are going to have
the exact same solution and you know
maybe maybe someday somebody will come
up with a better approach for this but
from from my own experience it's been a
lot of trial and error and figuring out
what is really the right way for any
particular application to deploy a model
like this and then the last thing that's
worth noting too is that you know once
you're getting into this world of
building these models that are
continuously updating and improving over
time you're building software which is
just a very different paradigm of
programming you know beyond what your
typical data science intro would teach
you so you're thinking about things like
version control and automation and
scheduling and continuous integration
and setting up alerts just you know in
case your models start performing much
better or much worse than they had
before which might be a sign something's
wrong so you have to consider a lot of
these different things as you go not
just you know the basics of making a
machine learning model so here I've got
a framework that I would recommend as a
starting point and some of these things
can can vary depending on your
particular use case but I found this to
be a useful way to approach these kinds
of models first step is research design
that's something I note here is a manual
process pen and paper doesn't literally
have to be pen and paper but the point
here is that before you ever start to
code it's critically important as it is
in every data science project but
particularly in these kinds of models to
think about what your research design is
in that you know what are you predicting
what what is it that you're modeling
what is the data generating process
looks like what is the application you
know how is this going to be sustainable
over time before you ever start writing
code it's important to think about these
and and particularly so in a model in
models like these where you know over
time if you're not paying attention
things can get worse and worse and worse
and often these are the kind of models
you use for critical
processes and infrastructure and so
forth in any data-driven organization
once you get through there you go
through a you know your pretty standard
process of development and then
production ization and then you deploy
and when you deploy again as I mentioned
earlier that's the point where you take
those predictions that come out of your
model and you put them in some process
in the real world there that's going to
eventually lead to those new results
that feed into a retrained model which
goes back and gets deployed again and
that's the cycle of sustainable models
and every so often you need to go back
and do true revalidation you might build
in some automated checks just to make
sure things are working as expected as
you go but with a model like this I
would highly recommend that every so
often you know whether it's it's every
day every week every month you know you
actually go back and do it as if you
were doing it for the first time make
sure the model makes sense that it's
doing what you're expecting that the
patterns you're seeing are the kinds of
patterns you would expect given the
model design that you have and if you
find that either something's not working
right or you just spot some opportunity
for improvement that's when you go back
to development that's when you go back
and say well the model could be better
I'm gonna make it better and that's a
key thing in these models they're never
done you know as long as you're using
them they are not completed if they're
completed you're missing out on
opportunities to improve because there's
always ways to improve in these so the
critical thing in making a sustainable
model work is what I call diverse data
and the context here is that the reason
you would make a sustainable machine
learning model which generates its own
training data more or less is that you
get that for free you're not you're not
incurring cost to go out and do to do
independent data collection so just as
an example from my own work you know I
did a lot of work in politics where the
typical process for making a model would
start out with a survey you go out you'd
survey 5 10 maybe 20,000 people and you
ask them some questions and you have
information from say a voter file from
consumer databases from voter contact
histories and so forth and you use that
to generate a model that you can use to
create predictions for every other voter
in a state or in the country we used to
do that all the time we do
for things like not only who are you
going to vote for or are you likely to
to turnout but we'd also think about
things like you know debt modeling
demographics or issue positions or how
likely you are to become a volunteer you
know these are all different kinds of
political models that we make and the
ones that are based on surveys they
involved a lot of cost upfront and you
can't always do that in terms of just
having the resources to go with you
original data collection every time you
want to update a model so the benefit in
these sustainable designs is that you
get that information basically as just
an organic part of the process
the trade-off here is that the data is
not as good it's not you know this
perfect random sample you might get if
you go out and do a survey you know
instead you're getting data which you
know there is there's bias be baked into
because you're not going out and
collecting data at random that's the
whole point of you know doing the doing
targeting or you know tailored ad
content or what-have-you
you're not doing it at random this is
that exploration exploitation trade-off
I was talking about the key here is that
these biases if you're doing doing this
right can be overcome and there are two
basic things you need to think about one
is coverage namely that you know if you
focus too narrowly in in one particular
area you know for example if you are
doing fundraising targeting which one
that was one of the biggest models I
made at the DNC
that we directed all the the voter
direct mail fundraising so if you've
received mail from the DNC in the past
couple years asking for money I'm sorry
that was me basically you know this was
like the most important one of the most
important models we made and the thing
is is you know if you just drill down a
really narrow set of targets the problem
is you don't learn about all the people
you're not asking you don't learn what
they would do and I'll talk more about
that in a minute but the point here is
that you know your system model is not
going to be sustainable if you don't
have enough coverage to make your model
change course over time and try new
things
the other part is where I'll reliability
and again I'll give a very practical
example of this in a minute but the idea
is you know you're you're putting these
predictions out into the wild you're
rating data which isn't necessarily
coming from you know the same process
you might find if you were to just be
randomly casting about and collecting
original data you know there's some bias
baked into this and if you don't if you
don't understand the data generating
process that you're using the issue that
will come up is that the data that you
have will not be an accurate reflection
of the data that you don't have you know
the relationships in the real world if
they're not reflected in your data it
can lead you to wrong conclusions so
just to illustrate and I should say all
of these slides have already made it
available there on my github page I've
linked to them from Twitter so no need
to to write everything down and I may
breathe through a few of these and you
might want to go back and check in more
detail but so the first example when I
was talking about coverage is when
you're talking about narrowing down to
some kind of target universe like like
for fundraising or say if you're
directing different kinds of
advertisements or different kind of
recommendations you know if you find
early on hey this group of people
responds best to our fundraising appeals
or or this ad works way better than the
other ad and you just focus on that then
what's gonna happen is you're not going
to collect any kind of information that
would change what you think and what you
do so in this example you know these are
just very token non real data examples
but basically there's you know three
different clusters of potentially good
targets in here and what happens is the
first time you run the model it finds
one of them and the next time you run
the model it just drills down into that
one again and again and it's ignoring
these other potential areas and in the
real world one of the ways this this can
look like is when I started doing direct
marketing targeting at the DNC there was
actually a rule in place that nobody
nobody would send mail to somebody who
hasn't already donated if they're under
the age of 65 and this was based on
findings from earlier targeting which
found well hey look make sense from a
logical point of view that people who
are of retirement age are more likely to
read their mail and respond to it so
yeah I can I can see where somebody got
that idea that you know they sent out a
bunch of mail and found that people 65
and upward donate
much higher rates the problem is is they
stop mailing anybody under age 65 and
well the the there's a sustainability
problem when you are soliciting new
donors who are over the age of 65 they
you know it's a limited population and
that wouldn't be such a big deal if we
were a really small nonprofit sending
out you know five or ten thousand pieces
of mail we were sending out anywhere
between one in five million pieces of
mail every month so we can exhaust that
population really quickly but the other
thing of course is you know once they
get on your donor list
they don't necessarily stay on that
donor list for that long so the
long-term value of those new donors
you're bringing in actually isn't as
great as if you get somebody to become a
first-time donor when they're in their
30s or 40s or 50s but what we found is
you know I I came into this and said you
know what let's relax this let's walk it
back we didn't have any data from
anybody under the age of 65 but we said
well you know what let's basically
effectively treat those people has the
bottom of that age range see what
happens and turns out the first time we
sent mail our best-performing age group
was 50 to 64 because in part we'd
exhausted all the good targets from 65
and up because these were this was the
non donor targets once they donated for
the first time they were taken out of
the universe so it turns out over time
what had happened was actually a
different age range was better because
we'd exhausted all good targets and we
would have never figured that out if we
had only focused continually on that one
particular age range of 65 and up the
other problem you can run into is if you
put too much stake in data that's
generated from a biased process and here
we've kind of got the opposite situation
we actually have a pretty clear pattern
if you can see all the data but what's
been observed so far is actually a
non-random set and so the model here
says well okay we find these three
clusters so let's focus on those and it
keeps trying to focus on those and
ignores that broader pattern that's
actually there in a way it's the the
opposite of what we saw before it may
focus specifically on these different
areas but you know it's relying too
heavily on data that actually went in
that in practice is not
it's not performing the way you expect
so one thing that we worked on a lot at
the DNC another kind of sustainable
model was for volunteer recruitment this
is a model that we put together for
campaigns to target people who could
potentially become volunteers and you
know the dirty little secret of it is it
was a way to get campaigns to share
volunteer lists with each other because
campaigns are generally terrible at that
not only are they very protective of it
but generally the day after an election
all the staff goes and gets another job
so often times there isn't even anybody
anybody to ask after a campaign for
permission but at the DNC we put in to
him to effect a data sharing agreement
where after a campaign we could pool
these volunteer histories together and
then use them to create this model and
what it did was it basically looked and
found people who not just looked like
volunteers but were people who if we
were to ask them to volunteer in the
future would be likely to say yes
and when I first ran this what I what I
ran into was a case where I I could have
sworn I basically coded something
backwards because what I found is in the
population I was looking at the best
targets were actually Republicans and
and you know first I thought I just made
a mistake I assumed I coded something
backwards and then I tried to
rationalize it and I thought well you
know maybe it's that say people who are
older and more you know settled down and
live in the suburbs maybe they're just
more likely to volunteer because you
know they they live that kind of
lifestyle and so it's the Democrats who
look more like Republicans in terms of
demographics maybe they're the ones who
are most likely to volunteer and I
started digging into this more and and
that was [ __ ] what I actually found
was that this was a bias problem in the
model that the problem was is I was
building a model which was based on
attempts to recruit volunteers and
here's the thing the only time a
Democratic campaign is going to attempt
to recruit a Republican to be a
volunteer is if they actually have some
other information that suggests they'd
be a good target like they signed up for
your mailing list they made it
they showed up in an event you know they
may be registered as a Republican on the
voter file but they've done something to
show the campaign that they're actually
supportive otherwise it wouldn't make
any sense at all to ask a Republican to
become a volunteer so what was happening
was that the model was looking at this
bias data and saying well you know
Republicans are actually great
Democratic volunteers let's ask more of
them and of course that's not how it
works
so in this case the solution wasn't
anything fancy we just finally had to
realize you know what let's just drop
the Republicans from our training sample
because that's obviously an outlier but
that's the point I'm trying to make here
that sometimes if your model can get too
caught up on these biased data
generating processes you can actually
ignore the real patterns that are in
there and get too focused on things that
don't really work once you extend them
out and the important thing is is you
know you're going to make mistakes like
that some of them might not be so
obvious but even in that case you should
make sure your model is open to change
and if it doesn't work the way that you
intended it picks up on that and and
changes its predictions going forward so
how do you make your day too diverse
well here are some five options and they
roughly go from at the top here a sort
of research focused approach of
deliberately collecting you know more
widely applicable data all the way down
to building something into your model
which allows for you to collect diverse
data without actually going out of your
way to to do specific research data
collection so the first one is what I
call broad-based sampling and that's
basically just sort of bridging that gap
between pure research data collection
and you know collecting it organically
through your process so in our
restaurant inspection models in Boston
we we send inspectors out to go to
places that we think are likely to have
violations but we also have regular
annual inspections between one two three
times depending on the kind of
establishment so every you know every
place basically is going to get checked
at least once a year so what that does
is it introduces new data from places
where we don't have any reason to think
that they're a good target for
inspection but we're going to do it
anyways so what that does is it keeps
diverse data pool in there so that you
know if we find that hey there's a
particular kind of restaurant or or you
know a particular characteristic that
actually predicts food safety violations
really strongly that we haven't been
accounting for that will make its way
into our data
the second is supplementation bringing
in outside data that can help create
more variety so when we were doing
fundraising we would not only take our
you know the targets that we were
identifying through our model we would
also target people who came in from
outside donor lists from other
organizations you know things like say
Emily's list or the the Democratic
Congressional Campaign Committee we
might share list with them and so we add
people in the trouble here of course is
that's again you know there's a bias in
that selection we have to account for
that that can be taken into account in
your model to some degree you just have
to take things with a grain of salt and
and build that into your feature set but
what it does it allows you to bring in
information about people or about other
circumstances or whatever it is you're
modeling that you wouldn't otherwise be
getting if you just relied on your
models predictions the third is what I
call waiting to learn and that's trying
to build in this learning into your
process so remember I talked about the
exploration exploitation trade-off and
how hard it is to make metrics well here
you would deliberately prioritize
instances where you know you you need to
get more information so what that might
mean is you know when you're
establishing a target list or you're
picking which ad to show somebody or
anything like that you incorporate
directly the uncertainty in your current
prediction as a way to prioritize
collecting new information in cases
where you have a lot of uncertainty the
fourth of these is what I call rough
targeting and this is this is probably
the most hacky solution here but it but
it actually works so the first time we
rolled out those volunteer models that I
mentioned a few minutes ago you know we
had them to whatever level of precision
we needed but you know what we realized
was well if we put out what is typical
in politics which is you put out a score
of somewhere between zero and 100 and
you know maybe you
rounded or with one you know one decimal
place what's gonna happen immediately is
every campaign it gets access to this is
going to go and contact the people with
scores of 100 and those people's phones
are going to blow up and they're never
gonna answer them again because they got
called by every campaign you know within
a hundred miles on the same day and so
instead what we did is we realized well
you know there's two things here one we
just don't want to blow up the list and
make it not work anymore but also we
want to collect more data because this
is the first iteration and so what we
decided to do was to round the scores so
the first iteration of this we actually
made it a zero to ten score and rounded
them so that basically and these are
these are ranked scores so you know zero
whereas basically Republicans you're
likely Republicans you know and and you
had deciles of one to ten among the
likely Democrats and so what happened is
the top targets it was actually a pretty
broad group they were still you know top
ten percent but the campaigns weren't
able to distinguish between those and so
what it did is it forced them to bring
in people who you know they weren't the
bottom tier targets but they also
weren't the very top based on our model
and so what that meant was we got a
pretty wide swath of the electorate so
the next time we did this we were able
to make the model better and better and
better because we were getting pretty
pretty wide coverage in the last of
these is what I call high churn modeling
which is you don't actually go out of
your way to collect diverse data but the
thing you do do is you make sure that as
soon as your model doesn't work the way
you plan or you learn something about a
particular case or a particular
individual that makes you want to change
your prediction you make sure your model
will respond to that so one of the
things we did was phone quality scores
this is what the DNC used to assign what
the best phone number is for any given
individual in the country they're about
two hundred million or so registered
active voter registrations in the
country a lot of those are outdated
there are only about 160 million actual
registered voters but in any case for
those 200 million active registrations
we had about 500 million phone numbers
so we need to figure out how to match
them up and what we did is we built
models for any given komban
of those two we basically would come up
with a prediction of how likely it is
that it's a working number and that if
somebody answers it's going to be the
person you want to get on the phone and
so the thing we did with this model is
we built it to rerun every night with
the results of all the day's calls made
by every campaign in the country that
was using the central voter contact
software so by the leading up to the
2014 election you know we were talking
about 10 million calls a week we're
filtering into this system and what we
would do is as soon as we would get a
case where you know if if I tried
calling Ben over there and you know
found out his numbers been disconnected
but I have another number for Ben unless
I know that number is also terrible
what's going to happen is within 24
hours I'm gonna swap out the new number
for the old number and so the next time
somebody tries to call Ben they'll be
calling on a different number and we'll
get information about that and maybe
that number sucks too and we don't have
any good numbers but at least then we
know ok this is this is a person we
don't have any good numbers for you know
let's go out to our our consumer data
partners and source a new phone number
for him and that allowed us to really
turn that over quickly it also meant
that you know if our model was making
predictions like the number it said was
best
he's invest that was corrected very
quickly so finally to wrap up I just
want to offer a few basic
recommendations for making these sorts
of models one is in terms of features
the the key here is building in features
that create heterogeneity in your
predictions that you don't just as I
mentioned earlier drill down into one
particular area of your feature space so
some of this is incorporating things
like cyclical patterns over time but you
also want features that will change
whether that's you know truly dynamic
features you know from a external
sources that can change on a regular
basis or things like component models
where you you build in things like
models of say demographics you know we
built in models of like language
preference and household composition and
marital status and so forth and we
updated those models regularly and so
that would offer something that would
add some variety into our our other
models that you know when we would rerun
and rerun and rerun you know we'd have
variation in the predictions which meant
we would end up trying out
more of the more of the feature space
over time but I think most important is
incorporating individual histories so
that example of you know Ben's phone
number when I try to call Ben I want to
make sure that feeds back into the model
because that's something where you know
I don't just want to fix the model I
want to make sure the model fixes its
own predictions because that's the whole
point of doing these sustainable models
you know the the outcome of the model is
also your data generating process and so
by doing that you know you don't want to
just make a better model you want to
make better predictions for the the
individual cases that you're predicting
for second part when you're actually
building the model you want one that's
going to incorporate the complexity of
different kinds of interactions between
your features
you know incorporating things like
nonlinear patterns so I have a huge fan
of of tree based models for these sorts
of things using ensembles retraining
frequently all of these things are based
on the idea of you know every time you
run the model you should get different
predictions that's what allows your
model to change and improve over time
and it also allows it to try more of the
possible feature space to keep your data
diverse and then lastly you know
evaluating your model as you go I like
to do what I call out of context
validation so this is different from
your typical out-of-sample validation
where you just hold out something that's
generated from the same data generating
process you know I think particularly
for these kinds of models it's actually
much more important to make sure that
they work outside of the data you're
using for training so for example rather
than if we're doing fundraising models
you know rather than just holding out a
random 10 or 20% of the total set of you
know of fundraising mailers that we had
sent over the past year or two what
instead we would do when we were when we
were testing out the model to make sure
it works is we'd hold out the most
recent couple months and build a model
based on the data up until then and so
that was the proxy for what we were
actually trying to do which is predict
how something's going to work in the
future
and that ended up telling us a very
different thing because it meant that
any patterns that changed we didn't have
any data to tell us what the patter the
temporal patterns would be beyond what
was in that that initial training set
and you know we would do this too
stage model obviously we'd retrain with
all the data after the fact but to just
make sure that everything we were we
were trying to do was working correctly
you know we do that pretty extensive
validation also going forward you know
you do need to stay on top of things
track how your model is doing over time
be willing to change it and I think one
of the things that's really important is
you know your model should should either
stay about the same or get slightly
better over time
you know if it's getting worse you
probably want to to mix something up try
something new you know it might just be
that you're you're using a algorithm
that's not covering enough of the
feature space say or you know you want
to add some more of writing your data
but also be worried if your model gets
too good because it might mean that
either there's something wrong in your
model or you know your balance of
exploration and exploitation is a little
off you know I think models that that
predict too well are probably the worst
case scenario I'd much rather have a
model again get worse then get
dramatically better because that often
means data leakage so particularly be on
the lookout for that and and make sure
that you know you've built that in your
system particularly if you're gonna
automate so the final bit I think this
applies to all of machine learning but
especially for these kinds of models
first understand your data understand
what that means in the real world what
the data generating processes how your
data and predictions are going to be
applied and make sure you you have an
understanding of that before you start
making a model because ultimately if
you're making a model of something you
don't understand your model is going to
be terrible so don't do that please
second one sanity checks you know I'm
not the sort of person who thinks
machine learning should be telling us a
lot of things we could never figure out
on our own
I think machine learning works best when
it's common sense at scale namely that
you know what computers are good at is
synthesizing a ton of information all at
once and and using that to generate a
very simple prediction in the end with
our restaurant inspection models for
example you know we use basic things
about restaurant characteristics and
inspection history and so forth we also
do things like bringing Yelp reviews and
we don't expect every restaurant
inspector to read you know every yelp
review for every restaurant in their
area every week but a computer can do
that just fine so that's really where we
add a lot of value and figuring out how
to take all those
combine them into one prediction that's
where computers are really good if
you're getting results that don't make
sense to you I would be really skeptical
about your model you know I think those
kinds of basic sanity checks even if you
can't understand all of the causal
relationships or you know it's not a
very simple linear relationship in your
model it still should make some kind of
sense look at things like you know
what's the distribution of predictions
across the distribution of features and
so forth build in some basic things
along the way and then finally you're
going to screw up every one of these
models is imperfect as is every model
obviously but you know these models are
hard you're going to need to change them
over time
you know best-case scenario you make a
model that's okay generally from the
start and then you have opportunities
for improvement but be aware you'll
probably screw something up along the
way or something will change in the
underlying data whenever you're doing
fundraising we had one you know one
round where our model got way better and
and the problem was was that turns out
we were sharing fundraising lists with
this consortium that was generating you
know this consumer data file that we
were happen to be using in our work and
we had started doing that a few months
after I started making these models so
all of a sudden from one month to the
next these consumer data features
started getting really powerful turns
out it's because there was data leakage
I didn't recognize that they were
actually incorporating our results but
they turned out to be really really
great predictors and that kind of stuff
just happens so be aware of it don't
don't stress about it just be on the
lookout and make sure you pay attention
so with that um we're just about the end
but if anybody has any any questions
yeah yeah I median is a good stat for
that because I have it say hours you
know this was something when we were
doing the fundraising models for example
we would do we would send a big mailing
once
and so at least once a month Hyatt and
nightwear I was just pretty much
resigned to being on my couch till 5:00
in the morning felt like doing all the
runs because ultimately you know
something would always go wrong and I
needed to kind of babysit as it went the
night before we actually cut the the
final list and so you know sometimes
it's really simple sometimes you
understand what's going on
sometimes it takes I've had cases where
it takes days I think one of the keys
that I found is build in those checks
build in the checks where for example
what we would do with that is you know I
would output the top the top percentile
of predictions I would look at the
features for those and I would see you
know what is the how does that compare
to the mean across the entire group and
so if we found for example in that case
of the consumer data file would that
happen to have data leakage you know
what what we were finding is oh wait you
know the average value or the average
feature value for our top predictions
was way way higher like like you know
orders of magnitude higher and to the
point where it just wasn't credible and
similarly looking at you know feature
importances and so forth I think just
planning to build all that stuff in your
process in a way it's planning to do the
debugging from the get-go and
fortunately you know when we're talking
about how much time all this takes this
is something we're going back to my
point of building software turning this
into a package where you just build this
into something that then you can reuse
across all your different models hugely
valuable I mean a lot of these just
basic checks of like the relationships
between your features and your outcomes
beyond just basic feature importances I
think that's something that's worth
doing for every model even if you don't
spend a ton of time digging into it it's
good to have and be able to refer to and
if nothing else it's also very helpful
to explaining how your models work to
people who aren't data scientists who
might not understand it but you know
they can understand that say if
somebody's volunteered for a campaign in
the past they're more likely to
volunteer in the future being able to
just say you know the that 50% of people
in that top bucket had been volunteers
you know in the last cycle that makes a
lot of intuitive sense for somebody
who's not a data scientist so you know I
I think that just something should
process for well we're a union shop so
nobody's on call you know I'm on call I
I'm the one non-union person so if it's
after hours it's me
you know realistically though like the
the restaurant selection models for
example which which Ben was the person
who made that's why I used him in that
that contact example you know that runs
once a week we deliver new predictions
on Friday it gets used you know starting
Monday by our inspectional Services
Department so you know in terms of
syntax errors I mean I think that's a
very general programming question and
hopefully hopefully you've worked out
the kinks before you put things into
production like that but but yeah this
stuff always comes up I think you know
all the standard recommendations around
things like unit tests and integration
tests you know particularly apply to
these sorts of models we have an
engineer for that yeah I mean that I'm
just thinking the fundraising models you
know where it's very easy to add to an
ensemble you know try is going back and
forth between you know am i using extra
trees or random forests oh wait I can
use both oh wait I can building gradient
boosting and you know eventually I've
got like a dozen different algorithms in
play when I did that I found out at the
end I went back and you know compared
the performance in retrospect of the
entire ensemble versus just picking the
best of them
the best you know the the best algorithm
and actually wasn't that different I
think it just has to be a conscious
choice to recognize that you know
there's overkill in building in
complexity and I think dealing with all
of these exceptions oh we have one point
though
think that is crucial that I didn't make
earlier is is try to solve the problems
in your ETL process and your general
data flows one of the reasons we
actually when we had problems with
fundraising models what most often was
the case was the data that got entered
was bad because a lot of that was being
done by hand by our male vet the the the
the vendor that sends the mail in the
vendor that collects mail that comes in
you know if there were data problems
there it would feed into the model the
model would break and I think solving
those problems at the source can help to
avoid a lot of those those ad hoc fixes
along the way because we certainly had a
lot of them there was a lot of like if
the mailing is from this month make this
change the coding you know that this is
this is one of those things where it's
like getting to know your data is partly
important because that will help you fix
it well I mean you don't automatically
know you don't know unless it's tried
like for example the phone the phone
contact ability models you know we
wouldn't know unless somebody actually
tried that phone number and so there are
a lot of cases where you know for
example of Massachusetts phone numbers
suck in there because master doesn't
have a lot of competitive races and so
there weren't a lot of campaigns trying
out those phone numbers I you know I
think if you're not getting it from
anywhere I don't know that it quite
falls in this category of model but
certainly there will be cases where
you're you're getting feedback from a
sort of narrow set and you have to kind
of make some assumptions about how that
applies elsewhere I think that kind of
gets back to that point of making sure
your model is responsive to differences
in the patterns that it's observing and
you know if if for example you know the
Senate race in Massachusetts next year
ends up being super competitive and a
ton of phone calls get made then it
should be you know the models should be
able to react to that and and start
fixing those numbers pretty quickly once
we find oh wait it's not actually
working as we intended
I won't say that I've salted predictions
before but I won't say that I haven't
either I mean it just in the sense of
you know if your if your model isn't
giving you diversity and you need that
for the model to work then then you need
to be deliberate about adding in new
data collection and sometimes that might
mean well the example I gave you the
volunteer scores where you know we knew
we could we could give better targets
than what we actually delivered and the
reason was is for the sustainability of
the model you know it was important that
we we got data back from a wider set of
people and so that in part gets to that
relationship you have between the the
data scientists and the stakeholder he's
actually going to be using it you know
and and it's important for the
stakeholders to understand for a model
like this that the data coming back is
critical to making sure the model works
long-term and so that you know if
they're not giving you money to go out
and collect data they have to be able to
help in some other way which might mean
you know going and calling phone numbers
or inspecting restaurants or knocking on
doors or whatever in a case where you
otherwise might not because based on
what you know now that doesn't seem
ideal but it's important to the
long-term success of the model I think
I'm getting the sign that's time to
leave so thank you all for attending and
good